to go buy some t-shirts right all i
wanted was like one solid color you know
it took me 20 minutes just to find a
t-shirt that was just like one solid
color you know because nowadays all the
t-shirts they have like those like those
stupid like balls to the wall sports
slogans across them
you know what i mean they say like above
the rim or like life short play high
there's like some 60 pound dork standing
there wearing the shirt going yeah
yeah i'm crazy i got no fear
i think you should have the real slungs
across these t-shirts like no girlfriend
living at home with parents
they're losers
these are the same people they go out
and they buy like those air jordans and
the shack shoe thinking it's going to
make them like a better hoop player you
know
like 150 bucks he got the shack shoe i'm
going to be awesome
kicking the ball
it's like no dude you suck and now
you're poor
[Applause]